Democrats attack Attorney General Bill
Barr el hanout Maher blames Venezuelans
crisis on America and hey I saw a
ventures endgame and I have thoughts i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
oh yeah they're gonna be spoilers so I'm
just gonna warn you late in the show
when we do a ventures endgame if you
haven't seen the movie yet I would
recommend that you either fast forward
or that you pause it we'll get to all of
that in just a second first let me tell
you about legacy box so if you want to
give the greatest gift that you can give
I really believe this to anybody it's
hid the gift of their memories
preserving those memories because as we
get older we have those memories stacked
up in our garage or there's backs up in
our phone there we have a bunch of crap
that we haven't done anything with and
it's moldering out there it's falling
apart we've got all over the photos from
our grandparents before our parents what
are you gonna do with all that stuff
we'll how about changing it from analog
formats to digitizing it there are there
are lots of reasons to want to do this
you can save your family films prevent
photos from degrading or being lost
forever you're unable to play your
recordings because you don't have a VCR
anymore well why don't you just
translate that over to a digital format
you can ensure your family history is
preserved forever send your legacy box
filled with old home movies and pictures
they will do the rest over at legacy box
they'll professionally digitize your
moments onto a thumb drive digital tail
motor DVD I've used it for my family you
should too it's really fantastic
they have easy-to-follow instructions
safety barcodes included for every item
receive all your original recorded
moments back and well with perfectly
preserved digital copies get
personalized updates at every step and
receive up to 12 personalized email
updates along the way legacy box is the
world's largest most trusted digitizer
of home movies and photos all the work
is done by hand right here in the United
States there's never been a better time
to digitally preserve your memories so
go visit legacy box comm today to get
started plus for a limited time they're
offering my listeners an exclusive
discount go to legacy box comm slash Ben
and get 40% off your first order that's
a legacy box comm slash Ben save 40%
today gets started preserving your past
legacy box comm slash Ben important gift
as well as just a really meaningful one
legacy box.com slash man he can save 40
percent today okay so we begin with the
democrats were very very angry Attorney
General William Barr today the big story
is that William Bar has said that he
would not testify before a House panel
the Justice Department is according to
Politico the Justice Department
a double-barreled rebuff two Democrats
on Wednesday informing the House
Judiciary Committee that Attorney
General William Barr would not show up
for his scheduled testimony before the
panel and that the department would not
comply with the subpoena for Special
Counsel Robert Muller's full report the
administration has the nerve to dictate
our procedures it's simply part of the
administration's complete stonewalling
of Congress period okay so a couple of
things it's not a complete stonewalling
of Congress to turn over Muller's entire
report to Congress that is not a
stonewalling of Congress and by the way
certain Congress people haven't seen the
unredacted material so the notion that
Congress has not seen the unredacted
material even that is not particularly
true also it is not the job of the
Justice Department to be the
investigators on behalf of Congress
there is a separations of powers in the
Constitution a separation of powers
which means Congress has investigative
power and they can subpoena things and
the Justice Department which works for
the executive branch is not mandated to
turn over those things this is why the
president can declare executive
privilege it's why the Justice
Department can point out that it does
not have to under regulations turn over
underlying materials and investigations
can you imagine if the power of Congress
extended to the ability to go to the DOJ
and then ask for all underlying
confidential grand jury testimony I mean
if it extended to that you know that
Congress would immediately leak that
stuff into the public sphere you know
that Congress would immediately take
that stuff and blow it up the reason
that William bar is not turning over the
unredacted materials in the grand jury
testimony is number one some of that
stuff is classified and number two it is
not the job of Congress to be able to
grab grand jury testimony that is being
attained and obtained by the Justice
Department under threat of criminal
prosecution
that's not Congress's power Congress has
its own investigative power they've got
subpoena power they've got the ability
to hold people in contempt but they do
not have law enforcement power there is
a difference between Congress and the
law enforcement arm of the government
which is the executive branch I think
bill Barr is completely right to say I'm
not turning over unverified grand jury
gossip that was not included in the
final Mullen report to you that is well
within his purview the Thursday hearing
which was set to examine bars handling
of the Mullen report would have included
an extra hour
to allow committee lawyers to question
the Attorney General the Justice
Department had argued would be
inappropriate for staffers to question a
cabinet member and as a result Barr
backed out this of course is indeed the
prerogative of the executive branch they
don't have to agree to any of the
conditions that Congress sets on them
and then if it ends up in court and ends
up in court if Congress chooses to hold
somebody in contempt or impeach they
can't hold somebody in contempt or
impeach there is a solution to this if
they want to impeach Breyer they can go
for it and they are talking about
impeaching Barr but again they're doing
so not even on the basis that he is now
being obstructive they're doing so on
the basis that he's been obstructive in
the past which is weird because the
conversation has gone something like
this Democrats to bar why are you
obstructing this investigation where is
the molar report bar it's in front of
you on the table printed out and in
public view for everyone to see
Democrats obstruction though that's how
this conversation is going to cover up
this is this is wild stuff so Democrats
of course are trying to play politics
with a mullah report that did not give
them what they wanted namely a clear
cause of action for impeachment or
certainly a criminal prosecution of the
President of the United States Jerry
Nadler who is deeply dishonest about all
this stuff the representative from New
York who once used to believe that the
executive branch didn't have the
necessity to turn over these sorts of
reports during the Clinton era he says
given his lack of candor in describing
the work of the special counsel our
members were right to insist that staff
counsel be permitted to question the
Attorney General I understand why he
wants to avoid that kind of scrutiny
Nadler added he is terrified of having
to face a skilled attorney well last I
checked these Congress people are
supposed to be skilled attorneys I mean
I'm glad they're acknowledging that
they're idiots now but it is not it is
not William bars decision to have to sit
he doesn't have to sit in front of a
bunch of lawyers who are unelected
bureaucrats to grill him so they can
catch him in some sort of perjury trap
Justice Department spokeswoman Terry
Cooper countered that Nagler had
established quote unprecedented and
unnecessary conditions for the hearing
adding quote Congress and the executive
branch are co-equal branches of
government each have a constitutional
obligation to respect and accommodate
one another's legitimate interests in a
separate letter Assistant Attorney
General Stephen Boyd told labeler that
his subpoena for the full unredacted
Mullah report plus the underlying
evidence and grand jury information was
not legitimate oversight the department
has
unresisted congressional attempts to
rummage through his files Boyd wrote he
added that Naylor had issued the
subpoena knowing that apartment could
not lawfully provide the unredacted
report that the committee lacks any
legislative purpose for seeking the
complete investigative files and that
processing request would impose a
significant burden on the department
Kneedler says he'll hold Barr in
contempt of Congress if the department
doesn't turn over the unredacted mullah
report and all of the underlying
evidence in the next day or two for
notes on how effective it is to hold an
Attorney General in contempt he should
turn to his Republican colleagues who
once held Eric Holder in contempt and
then did nothing about it and Eric
Holder is now sitting out there
proclaiming from his perch on moral high
how terrible William bar is the Chairman
also said he could issue a subpoena to
compel bars attendance at a future
hearing the committee had teed up the
clash earlier on Wednesday after a tense
party line vote on establishing the
ground rules under the motion adopted by
the Democrats on the committee the
attorneys for the Democratic and
Republican sides of the panel would have
had an hour equally divided it's a
question bar who had threatened to back
out of the hearing if that was the
arrangement Democrats said that despite
DOJ claims there is ample precedent to
use staff attorneys Republicans have
jumped to bars defense asserting it
would be disrespectful to have anyone
but lawmakers questioned the Attorney
General now again I don't see the
purpose why if I'm bar I don't do that
because then I'm basically testifying in
the open without the help of my own
legal counsel in danger of perjury from
lawyers whose job it is to create what
we call perjury traps now there are
people out there who say there's no such
thing as a perjury trap just tell the
truth well sometimes you can tell a
version of the truth and people will not
believe you and they will still
prosecute you for perjury right this is
for example when Bill Clinton said he
didn't know what the meaning of is is
that is a very lawyerly answer for
example well borrow could give a
lawyerly answer and still be accused of
lying in fact they're members of
Democratic Congress who have suggested
that he's lying right now and he has not
yet lied it's pretty amazing
well the Democrats on the House
Judiciary Committee are very upset about
this so upset that they brought a bucket
of fried chicken to the House Judiciary
Committee it's pretty incredible so
Steve Cohen who's another one of the
geniuses in the Democratic House he
showed up to the hearing with a ceramic
chicken and a bucket of fried chicken
which he proceeded to chomp
and then talk about how bar was a
chicken you guys get the you got it like
he's a chicken like he's scared
basically Steve Cohen is needles from
Back to the Future 2 pretty what are you
chicken McFly Oh being a full-fledged
silly person chicken bar should have
shown up today and answered questions he
was afraid of Barry Burke he was afraid
of Norm Ison Attorney General who's
picked for his legal acumen and his
abilities would not be fearful of any
other attorneys question him for 30
minutes this man was picked to be Roy
Cohn and to be Donald Trump's fixer the
black socks looked clean compared to
this team it's a sad day in America a
sad day in America here's my ceramic
chicken guys take me seriously
chicken bar by the way I'm really
considering the opening now in
discussion with my producers opening a
restaurant called chicken bar it sounds
delicious would be many types of chicken
there'd be teriyaki chicken there'd be
fried chicken there would be chicken ala
king like all sorts of chicken it sounds
great and William Burroughs picture
would grace the entrance
this chicken bar yeah I think you see
I'm taking you super seriously when you
say it's a sad day at America as you
will they ceramic chicken at me
Steve colored don't worry guys this is
super serious stuff Democrats are taking
this really seriously they've uncovered
wrongdoing so much wrongdoing that the
entire report is sitting on a desk in
front of them like right there
then James Comey sounds off so that's
always exciting James Comey who has
spent the last year-and-a-half couple of
years wandering the woods staring at the
sights of nature sort of like Thanos
after the after the snap fingers you
just become a farmer just out there
staring at the trees and being all weird
well now James Comey is back to write an
op-ed for the New York Times in which he
attacks all of his former colleagues as
deeply corrupt he says people have been
asking me hard questions people are not
you dude like you standing in the mirror
asking yourself hard questions Jim's
coming that those aren't people butts
this just you it's okay this is what
happens and the leaders in the Trump
administration especially the attorney
general bill Barr who I have said was do
the benefit of the doubt how could mr.
Barr a bright and accomplished lawyer
start channeling the president in using
words like no collusion and FBI spying
well first
he used the words no collusion because
the report found no collusion an FBI
spying because spying means surveillance
and surveillance was taking place so
there's that
how could he downplay acts of
obstruction of justice as products of
the president's being frustrated in an
angry something he would never say to
justify the thousands of crimes
prosecuted every day that are the
product of frustration and anger
well actually Jim's coming since you
were incompetence at your job you tried
to rewrite the the classification
statutes to include intent as an
elements of the crime you said Hillary
Clinton didn't intend to expose
classified material to public scrutiny
and therefore she was not guilty of the
crime intent was not an element of the
crime you just rewrote the law to
include it you know we're intent is an
element of the crime obstruction of
justice
so in William bar goes to the
president's state of mind that's because
intent is an element of the crime
if James Comey had two brain cells to
rub together it would help well get some
more of James Comey on this in just a
second but first admit it you think
cyber crime is something that happens to
other people you might think that no one
wants your data or that hackers can't
grab your passwords or credit card
details you would be wrong stealing data
from unsuspecting people on public Wi-Fi
it's one of the simplest and cheapest
ways for hackers to make money when you
leave your internet connection
unencrypted it may as well be writing
your passwords and credit card numbers
on a giant billboard for the rest of the
world to see which is why I decided to
take action to protect myself from cyber
criminals I use Express at VPN
expressvpn secures and anonymizes your
internet browsing by encrypting your
data and hiding your public IP address
expressvpn has easy-to-use apps that run
seamlessly in the background of your
computer phone and tablet turning on
expressvpn protection that only takes
one click using expressvpn I can safely
surf on public Wi-Fi without being
snooped on or having my personal data
stolen for less than seven bucks a month
you can get the same expressvpn
protection that I have expressvpn is
rated the number one VPN service by
TechRadar it comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee protect your online
activity today find out how you can get
three months for free and expressvpn
comm slash Ben that's expr ESS VPN comm
slash ban for three months free with a
one-year package visit expressvpn comm
slash Ben to learn more go check them
out right now okay so James Comey
writing in the pages of the prestigious
New York Times he says how could William
Barr write and say things about the
report by robert muller the special
counsel that were apparently so
misleading they prompted written
protests from the special counsel
himself
note as we mentioned yesterday on the
show the letter did not actually accuse
William Barr of Miss stating the
conclusions of the Mullen report
basically what Muller wanted is for Barr
to include all of the color commentary
provided by Tom Musburger or whatever he
wanted all the color commentary that was
going to show how mean and cruel and
nasty Trump was without being criminal
and Barr kept saying I'm guys that's not
my job I'm not the nasty mean cruel
police I'm the police police it's my job
to prosecute crimes and if no crime
takes place not my job to talk about my
feelings about all of that nonetheless
James Comey I mean a guy who actually
did go out and talk about all of the bad
things Hillary Clinton is on and then
exonerate her now he's ripping on Barr
he says how could Barr go before the
Senate Judiciary Committee on Wednesday
and downplay Presidents Trump's attempts
to fire mr. Muller before he completed
his work well I didn't downplay that he
didn't downplay that the one thing that
he certainly did do was mention that
this was not a crime which is his job he
said what happened to these people I
don't know for sure
said James Comey people are complicated
so the answer is most likely complicated
okay thanks thanks psychologists doc
doctor Comey we really appreciate your
take on people are complicated how could
people be like this I don't know people
are complicated but I have some idea
from four months of working close to mr.
Trump and many more months of watching
him shape others a moral leaders have a
way of reviewing the character of those
around them sometimes what they reveal
is inspiring for example James Madison
was I know ver a principal a concept so
alien to mr. Trump it took days for the
president to realize what had happened
you know who didn't resign over
principle as I recall a tall gentleman
six foot nine kind of weird gawky gangly
tried to hide in the curtains one time
when Trump was talking to him you didn't
quit was fired I see his name rhymes
with James mommy I remember I remember
that remember that guy I remember that
guy he says that William bar and rod
Rosen Stein they have gone along with
President Trump because he because
President Trump just pressures people
and they fall prey to the pressure he
tried it with me I didn't go along with
it but these people will these people
will you can't say this out loud but in
a time of emergency with the nation led
by a deeply unethical person this will
be your contribution your personal
sacrifice for America
you're smarter than Donald Trump you're
playing a long game for your country you
can pull it off
some leaders have failed and gotten
fired by tweet of course to stay you
must be seen as on his team so you
promise further compromises compromise
compromise okay remember James Comey did
not quit he was fired hey so now we get
to what the Democrats have actually been
accusing bar of and this is bewildering
because what exactly are they accusing
bar of doing they're mad at him that he
won't talk with the lawyers
you know maybe bar should show up and
talk with the lawyers just to show them
that he can run circles around them but
there's no necessity for him to put his
life in danger the possibility of being
imprisoned for a perjury trap set by
Democrats for example or an attempt to
subpoena him in violation of for example
executive privilege there are a lot of
legal issues that arise whenever the
Attorney General testifies before
Congress which is why they do have a
negotiation about setting the ground
rules in the first place but what
exactly is bar accused of doing
no one knows he issued a four-page
letter it accurately summarized the the
findings of the Moller report even
Muller acknowledged that it accurately
summarized the findings of the Muller
report so he rose William bar testifying
yesterday and from the Senate Judiciary
Committee suggesting correctly that
focusing on his four-page synopsis when
the entire report is available is really
really weird I understood you to say and
these are my words not yours the first
concern that mr. Moore had he felt like
your letter wasn't nuanced enough
correct okay that problems been solved
as it not what was sort of solved by
putting out the whole report exact which
was the that's why I think this whole
thing is sort of mind-bendingly bizarre
because I made clear from the beginning
that I was putting at the report as much
of the report as I could okay so this of
course is true he put out as much of the
report as he could so what exactly why
are they focusing on a synopsis that is
obviated by the actual report this is
like William Bar writes a summary of a
book the book is publicly available and
you're mad at his summary even though
you could just buy the book bara also
mentioned hey guys like the Muller team
didn't recommend charges I hate to break
it to you but the Muller team had the
ability to recommend charges to me and
they did not do so they declined to do
so here's Barr reminding Democrats of
this fact as the lower team changed its
mine on its conclusions its conclusions
as to what as to collusion
conspiracy of the conspiracy not that
I'm aware of so the decision not to
bring an indictment against the
president for conclude collusion
conspiracy with Russia has not changed
no it hasn't
and the conclusion not to bring an
indictment against the president for
obstruction of justice has not changed
no okay okay so that is not change none
of that has changed and then people on
the Left were saying well maybe the
reason that Mullins didn't prosecute is
because of the office of legal counsel
opinion that suggested that the
president could not be prosecuted for
obstruction of justice and Barr said
nope I talked him alone remember bars
under oath here he said I talked to
Miller three separate times and Miller
said he didn't decline to prosecute
because of the OLC opinion he declined
to prosecute because the evidence was
not clear one way or the other Special
Counsel Muller stated three times to us
in that meeting in response to our
questioning that he emphatically was not
saying that but for the OLC opinion he
would have found obstruction he said
that in the future the facts of a case
against the president might be such that
a special counsel would recommend
abandoning the OLC opinion but this is
not such a case we did not understand
exactly why the special counsel was not
reaching the a decision and when we
pressed him on it he said that his team
was still formulating the explanation
okay so in other words Muller explicitly
said to Barr there's an OLC opinion if
we thought the fact pattern overcame the
oil C opinion we would just recommend
the overthrowing of the oil C opinion we
don't think that happened here so Barr
asked Muller so why don't you just
recommend to charge we're not recommend
to charge and Mallard immured he said oh
we're coming up with an explanation the
real explanation is that Muller knew he
didn't have enough to charge here he
didn't want to exonerate President Trump
so instead he wanted to dump out into
public life all of the bad stuff about
Trump well well sort of washing his
hands of the whole thing as I said
yesterday Muller did not have the
intestinal fortitude to simply pull the
trigger on an obstruction of justice
charge nor did he have the legal backing
so instead he took what I think is a is
a pretty cheap way out by dumping all of
the material in public and then
suggesting well not up to me up to
William Barr
over there even though it is his really
responsibility to give a determination
as to whether he thinks this thing is
prosecutable or not and then Bart points
out by the way I didn't even exonerate
Trump I just said we didn't have enough
material to prosecute but I'm not
exonerating the guy on all of the stuff
that he did with regard to pressuring
his underlings on the Muller report you
in effect exonerated or cleared the
president
I didn't exonerate I said that we did
not believe that there was sufficient
evidence to establish an obstruction
offense which is the job of the Justice
Department and the job of the Justice
Department is now over that determines
whether or not there's a crime the
report is now in the hands of the
American people everyone can decide for
themselves there's an election in 18
months that's very democratic process
but we're out of it we have to stop
using the criminal justice process as a
political weapon
I love William bar having to educate
sitting senators in how law works it is
not my job to come up with stuff that's
mean or bad it's my job to determine
whether the law has been broken all the
bad stuff is out there you going to vote
against him vote against him this is
correct William Bar is getting a lot of
flack for suggesting that Muller's
letter to him was snitty it is in fact a
snitty letter as I mentioned yesterday
it was Muller not protesting that bar
had been dishonest in his letter but
protesting that bar hadn't sufficiently
captured his mood when he wrote the
mullah report so Barr is correct in this
characterization this letter was an
extraordinary act a career prosecutor
rebuking the Attorney General of the
United States memorializing in writing I
don't consider Bob at this stage of
career prosecutor he's had a career as a
prosecutor well he's a very eminent I
was the head of the FBI for 12 years I
know of no other instance of but he was
also political appointee and he was a
political appointee with me at the
Department of Justice I don't you know
the letters a bit snitty and I think it
was probably written by one of his staff
people okay pretty pretty hilarious so
you know Bart is correct about all of
this obviously you know he knows Muller
he had conversations with Muller and so
he feels like molars people were
probably ticked at Muller that virus
letter came out and that's probably why
this whole thing happened now in a
second we're gonna get to the Democratic
attempts to take down bar directly so
to say they fail because they don't
understand basic law and because this
whole thing is a railroading of the
highest order we'll also get to the
situation over in Venezuela where Ilhan
Omar has some words well gets all that
in just one second first Mother's Day is
coming up there's absolutely nothing
most of us wouldn't do to make sure the
special moms in our life are happy this
is where Sherry's berries comes in
cherries berries has special Mother's
Day berries designed just for Mom
they are topped with chocolate chips
pink shimmer sugar swizzles you choose
your delivery date to ensure mom gets
your gift of Sherry's berries exactly
when you want her to and your
satisfaction is always guaranteed let me
explain something
Sherri's berries their chocolates
they're their chocolate tasting
substances they're just spectacular okay
so they have a bunch of kosher products
I have personally tasted cherries
berries they're so good that after I had
some I then proceeded to spend all of
our money on cherries
I mean like boxes of cherries berries
products so good like the best sweets
you'll have ever had incredible
incredible worth the calories worth the
money worth all of it do not wait until
the last minute on this one visit
berries calm today to order freshly
dipped strawberries starting in 1999 for
the moms in your life to make mom really
happy can double the berries for just
ten bucks more Mother's Day is Sunday
May 12th
so visit berries calm that is BER RI es
calm click on the microphone in the
upper right corner enter my code Ben
show that's berries calm click the
microphone code Ben show cherries
berries I promise you she won't be
disappointed in you
you may disappoint to her your entire
life now you may just get an arrow do
well but I promise you you wanna make
your mom happy there's only one way to
do that properly that is berries calm go
to Sheree's berries and get yourself
from cherries berries for your mom she
will appreciate it and she'll probably
think that you're a better child also
enter my code Ben's show at checkout
when you click the microphone for that
special deal ok so Democrats have
decided that bar is nonetheless despite
the fact that bar has not actually
violated the law that he's not
obstructing anything they have decided
that he is obstructing something and
that secretly deep down in the cockles
of his heart
Muller was ready to prosecute Trump and
Muller just decided not to prosecute
Trump because what William bar waved a
magic wand he said the magic words and
then
Muller turned into a pumpkin or what the
funniest thing here was Democrats trying
to push bar to say that Donald Trump
should be prosecuted for non criminal
behavior
so the report which I have read the
entirety of summarized twice on the show
the report does not include evidence of
criminal conduct by the President of the
United States at least criminally
prosecuted conduct by the presidents of
the United States it includes a lot of
bad behavior a lot of immoral behavior a
lot of behavior that is not appropriate
for the President of the United States
to engage in that is not criminal
as William Bar the Attorney General
whose job it is to prosecute criminal
violations told Dianne Feinstein who
certainly knows better the senator from
California you still have a situation
where a president essentially tries to
change the lawyers account in order to
prevent further criticism of himself
well that's not a crime so you can in
this situation instruct someone to lie
no it has to be well to be obstruction
of justice the lie has to be tied to
impairing the evidence in a particular
proceeding okay that is called the law
his job is to enforce the law Dianne
Feinstein's job is to yell at him for
enforcing the law Kamala Harris tried
the same tactic this was pretty amazing
so Kamala Harris is now proclaiming that
Robert Muller did a bad job so we were
told for years the Robert Muller did a
great job I mean they're they're buying
votive candles they were they had shirts
with his face on it
Chelsea Handler said she wanted to sleep
with Robert Moore like the left was
Robert Muller was gonna save them all
and then Robert Muller didn't save them
he looked down at them and said no and
Senator Kamala Harris got very very
angry at this and so her suggestion is
that Robert Muller impacted a very bad
job and that William bar the Attorney
General should have gone around Muller
looked at all the underlying evidence
and then prosecuted and then prosecuted
president Trump based on evidence not
synopsized
not summarized by Robert Muller hey
Carmel Harris was the Attorney General
of California I promise you if one of
her lower-level prosecutors came to her
and say you know Attorney General I've
got this case I'm not gonna tell you
whether you should prosecute it or not
here's the evidence you think that
Kamala Harris is going to read the
synopsis and say you know what this
doesn't look like it rises to the level
of a crime for me or is she going to go
back through the
of thousands of pages of grand jury
testimony the 25 million dollars already
spent on the investigation she's gonna
go around that and come to her own
magical determination ignoring Muller so
the Democrats kept saying that bar is
going to ignore Muller then bar doesn't
ignore Muller and they're mad at him her
senator Kamala Harris being deeply
disingenuous counsels investigation
produced a great deal of evidence I've
led to believe it included witnesses
notes and emails witnesses congressional
testimony witnesses interviews which
were summarized in the FBI 302 forms
former FBI director Comey's memos and
the president's public statements in
reaching your conclusion did you
personally review all of the underlying
evidence no we accepted the statements
in the report as the factual record we
did not go underneath it to see whether
or not they were accurately accepted it
is accurate so in other words come Blair
it's like why did you trust Muller so
after years of you must trust Muller now
it's why did you trust him what you
wanted to look at it yourself why not
and I love Cory Booker in the background
they're kind of smirking along Cory they
just remind you you're running for
president against Kamala Harris and
she's drinking your milkshake right now
here's Komal Harris afterward saying bar
should resign based on what based on
nothing he made a decision and didn't
review the evidence no prosecutor worth
her salt would make a decision about
whether the President of the United
States was involved in an obstruction of
justice without reviewing the evidence
this Attorney General lacks all
credibility and has I think compromised
the American public's ability to believe
that he is a purveyor of justice
oh is that what happened here I remember
when Kamala Harris was fighting mad
fighting mad and it's her knee general
Loretta Lynch for not ignoring the
recommendation of James Comey and
looking at the underlying evidence to
bring the prosecution against Hillary
Clinton
I remember when Kamala Harris and the
Democrats were fighting mad oh wait no
that never happened because it's a much
bullcrap that she's spewing right there
it's just nonsense okay then if that's
and then you've got Richard Blumenthal
the senator from Delaware who lied for a
very very long time about his
involvement in Vietnam or calling Barr a
liar and saying the bar should resign so
he has got a lot of
ability to stand right here I think that
Attorney General William bar ought to
recognize that he has an obligation to
resign here I have called it the very
least for him to recuse himself from
those 12 to 14 ongoing investigations
into the President of the United States
in other jurisdictions he declined in
fact he ducked the question entirely as
to whether he has had any conversations
with the White House about them said he
couldn't recall a response that is very
difficult to believe so I think he
should resign okay so he should resign
by the way he's the senator from
Connecticut not Teller and then mazie
Hirono who's the worst of all says she
says you're a liar this is before she
asked him a question by the way she'd
asked him a question and then accused
him of lying to her she just said you're
a liar and a mean man and I hate you and
I don't like your hair
and you're ugly and you have bad glasses
and he smell senator mazie Hirono from
the great state of Hawaii
well done Hawaii now the American people
know that you are no different from Rudy
Giuliani or Kellyanne Conway or any of
the other people who sacrificed their
once decent reputation for the grifter
and liar who sits in the Oval Office you
once turned down a job offer from Donald
Trump to represent him as his private
attorney at your confirmation hearing
you told senator Feinstein that quote
the job of attorney general is not the
same as representing and quote the
president so you know the difference but
you've chosen to be the president's
lawyer and side with him over the
interests of the American people okay so
well done mazie Hirono I mean that's it
that's some hard-hitting questioning
right there Ted Cruz senator from Texas
whose guest on our program yesterday
sitting through all of this nonsense
senator Cruz has a rough job he actually
has to sit in these committees while
these Democrats say this stuff and then
be polite to them that's it that's a
very difficult job and the man does have
a lot of forbearance but you would have
to be the Zodiac killer obviously so
senator Ted Cruz he he he just rips on
the Democrats and you can see William
bar trying not to laugh as senator Cruz
does so the principal attack the
Democratic senators have marshaled upon
you it's an attack that I want people to
understand just how revealing it is if
this is their whole argument they ain't
got nothing so their entire argument is
general bar you suppress the 19 pages
that are entirely public that we have
that we can read that they know every
word of it and their complaint is it was
delayed a few weeks if that is their
argument I have to say that is an
exceptionally weak argument even bar
can't hold himself back at this point
the best reaction in all of this by the
way as always boy to Chris Matthews Oh
Emma's a safe got the morning come here
they show maybe watch it apart now goofy
last night and I have a few metaphors
what happened to William bar last night
I was watching some it was weird pizza
guy showed up knock the door lady
answered the door say I'm on a pizza
there's your pizza and then things get
all weird strange I watched that last
night made me think of mullet report
made me think a William bar I don't know
why cuz it's just how things going it's
crazy out of my go chris matthews go
once he's testified before mr. Morris
Gary the Special Counsel investigation
how can he now say I won't make the same
testimony in public claiming executive
privilege I think it is sort of like
virginity kind of thing once you start
talking about a matter of people in your
junior jurisdiction and then you say oh
I'm not doing it anymore you can't do it
once you've started so I understand that
so executive privilege works once you've
given it up you can't grab it back I'm
not gonna go with you I'm sorry about
that metaphor I use before I I've been
admonished already about it so I really
should have used it in fact like my
virginity that's really awkward gotta
come with the only time I've ever liked
Gamma lares I'm Larry's trying not to
burst out laughing and Chris Matthews Oh
William bar is like you know you didn't
assert executive privilege that he wants
to assert executive privilege like a
lady trying to hide her virginity I mean
what are gonna do carry it out carry
around town try show everybody she's a
virgin hey what what what is it like
biblical law ah Kathleen didn't do that
I don't know about Kathleen I know about
me I don't know anything just come over
here come out of this show
in this chair swivel around all weird
like Chris Matthews I'm sorry Shay
report Michael Isikoff what do you say I
love our media they're just great at
their jobs all right in a second we're
gonna get see the latest developments
from Venezuela so if I sit you
say things are not great but first and
can be a little frustrating especially
if you are in a hurry or running late to
find yourself at a railroad crossing
waiting for a train
you're sitting there and nothing's
happening and you're thinking okay I
could probably make it around these
little barriers here well if the signals
are going and the Train is not even
there yet you might feel a little
tempted to try to gun it and get across
the tracks don't do this ever this is a
stupid stupid idea
trains are often going a lot faster than
you expect them to be going and they
cannot stop so I think we hit the brakes
or blast the horn at you or something
and then stop that's not how it works
even if the engineer hits the brakes
right away it can take a train over a
mile to stop by that time what used to
be your car is just a crushed hunk of
metal and what used to be you is a
crushed hunk of human flesh it's good
times the point is you don't know how
quickly the train is going to arrive and
the train can't stop even if it's easier
and sometimes you can't see the train
properly and it can't see you properly
and even if it can it's gonna run you
over
the result disaster so if the signals
are on assume the train is on its way
please do not be a stupid oh and you
just need to remember you should stop
because of the train cannot okay so in a
second we are going to get to the
situation in Venezuela and our moral our
moral light in the US Congress is
speaking out about Venezuela I'll get to
that in just a second first you have to
go over to daily wire comm for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription to
daily wire comm when you do you get the
rest of this show live yet the rest of
Andrew Clavin show live you get the rest
of Michael knows the show live you get
the rest of Matt Walsh your show live
you get two additional hours of me every
single afternoon we have great guests
like yesterday we had on Arthur Brooks
from the American Enterprise Institute
and senator Ted Cruz also the show is
basically like an all-day show at this
point because I do this show in the
morning and then later I come back in to
do two more hours so I am doing like 24
hour news coverage from this desk right
here the least you could do is subscribe
and become part of the club also when
you get the annual subscription for 99
dollars a year you get this the leftist
here is how to recall tumblr it is
magnificent you will enjoy it you will
live it you will love it so go get one
of those and make your life better right
now also make sure that you give us a
follow at YouTube or iTunes and leave us
a review we always appreciate it we're
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
meanwhile here's the update from
Venezuela so the the dictator of
Venezuela Nicolas Maduro is still in
power the protests continue a pace in
Venezuela Venezuela Zohan Widow is
remaining defiant after a failed attempt
to oust Maduro
Maduro has now appeared in public with
soldiers these soldiers some of them are
Venezuelan soldiers and some of them
apparently are from Cuba according to
the BBC and a show of defiance against
his opponents Venezuelan president
Nicolas Maduro appeared flanked by
soldiers at an army base in Caracas on
Thursday
Maduro called on the armed forces to
oppose any coup plotter as clashes
between opposition supporters and
pro-government forces continued
opposition leader Juan widow tried on
Wednesday to spark a military defection
and forced Maduro from office white o
has urged public employees to strike to
undermine the government Maduro praised
the Army's loyalty on Thursday since
he's paying them off and they're running
over civilians in trucks calling on the
military to unite in defense of the
Constitution a constitution that he is
overridden personally he says no one
dare touch our sacred ground or bring
war to Venezuela he what he's trying to
do is draw the West into actual military
conflict so that he can then claim
imperialism is what is causing this as
opposed to an uprising by the Venezuelan
people who it turns out are not all that
fond of eating dog in January white or
declared himself at Venezuela's interim
leader he has the support of more than
50 countries including the United States
the UK and most of Latin America the
reason that people are unhappy with with
Maduro is because they were unhappy with
chavez increasingly because socialism is
a giant failed Venezuela is one of the
most oil-rich nations on earth the
average of Venezuelan adult has lost 24
pounds over the course of the chavista
regime on Wednesday both Pro and
anti-government supporters held
demonstrations in Caracas that were
initially peaceful their reports of
gunfire in the city a local NGO said
that one 27 year old had been shot dead
during the rally in the opposition
stronghold of Altamira at least 46
people were injured in clashes between
opposition supporters and the security
forces the white OH
posted video on Tuesday showing him with
a number of men in military uniform
saying that he had the the support of
the military that obviously has not
materialized as of yet and thus we have
what is effectively a stalemate
according to the Washington
post the United States was presented a
plan by Widow as to what exactly was
going to happen here there was a strong
suggestion that nicolas maduro might
peacefully fly to Havana on Monday the
plan started to fall apart because
Maduro had gotten wind of it and when
wydo responded by rushing ahead with his
plan anyway at dawn he released that
video after a day of bloody protests the
government was still intact the Trump
administration blamed Russia and Cuba
for keeping him in place and in
discouraging high-level defections the
White House has held an emergency
meeting of top national security aides
to mole next steps they say significant
progress on defense matters was made
throughout the day there were mixed
messages about what exactly the United
States military would do obviously those
there aren't really mixed messages
they're saying that we're not interested
in getting involved but all options are
on the table Obama used to use that
language all the time because as
president you constantly use that sort
of language
well there's one group to blame
according to ohon Omar you know our
moral leader she says that the u.s. is
responsible for what's been happening in
Venezuela the United States by us now it
should be noted the sanctions that were
placed in Venezuela we're not placed on
Venezuela as a country they were not
placed on in Venezuela's oil exports
they were placed and they're placed
specifically and four years on specific
leaders and business figures inside
Venezuela so this is just not true
Venezuela was destroyed from within
Ilhan Omar has never found a socialist
dictator that she couldn't cozy up to
here is another one so she's cozying up
to Nicolas Maduro worth noting here
Ilhan Omar thinks that you should
sanction Israel the only democracy in
the Middle East in a place where Muslims
are treated better than any place in the
Middle East
she thinks that that country should be
sanctioned Venezuela knows sanctions
she's not anti-semitic no guys she's
just a human rights advocate a lot of
the policies that we've put in place has
kind of helped lead the devastation in
Venezuela and we've sort of set the
stage for where we were arriving today
this particular bullying and the use of
sanctions to eventually intervene and
make regime change really does not help
the people of countries like Venezuela
and its
only does not help and it's not in the
interest of the United States it's not
in the interest in the people who
Venezuelan out to eat dogs dogs are
delicious
apparently and it's really in their
interest to continue under the auspices
of an illegitimate government that's
that's in their interest and if you
don't agree that's because you are an
Islamophobe or something right that's
that's that's the direction this is
going meanwhile the president of the
United States was honoring Yom Hashoah
today Yom Hashoah of course is the
International Day for the remembrance of
the Holocaust and that is perfectly
appropriate at a time when anti-semitism
is spiking anti-semitic attacks have
indeed spiked to the highest level in
decades according to the Associated
Press Israeli researchers reported on
Wednesday that violent attacks against
you spiked significantly last year with
the largest number reported number of
Jews killed in anti-semitic acts in
decades leading to an increased sense of
emergency among Jewish communities
worldwide capped by the deadly shooting
that killed 11 worshippers at
Pittsburgh's Tree of Life synagogue on
October 27th assaults targeting Jews
rose 13% in 2018 according to tel aviv
university researchers they recorded
nearly 400 cases worldwide with more
than a quarter of the major of violent
cases taking place in the united states
that spike was most dramatic in western
europe where jews have faced even
greater danger and threats in germany
for example there was a 70% increase in
anti-semitic violence and this is
because there are three types of
anti-semitism that are at work in
today's world there is left-wing
anti-semitism right-wing anti-semitism
and radical muslim anti-semitism and
each one of them poses a different sort
of threat so let's start with right-wing
white supremacist anti-semitism
right-wing white supremacist
anti-semitism not only does it exist it
is the most individually dangerous form
of anti-semitism to specific jews
meaning that if i see that a Jew was
shot up in in the united states i will
almost immediately assume that it is a
white supremacist because statistically
speaking it usually is and that is
because there are these marginalized as
they should be marginalized evil people
who find communities online self
radicalized almost like adjunct members
of Isis and then go and shoot Jews at
places like synagogues these same people
will go and try to burn down mosques or
shoot Muslims in mosques in many cases
so that's right-wing extremist
anti-semitism premises
semitism that is one ideology and the
type of danger that opposes is not a
political danger it is a is a safety
danger then there's left-wing
anti-semitism left doing anti-semitism
is the is the belief that the Jews are
in control of the world because the Jews
are disproportionately wealthy and
successful and don't agree with the
anti-biblical notions of the second left
and thus they ought to be quashed right
this would be Jeremy Corbyn in the UK it
would be Ilhan omar in the united states
now left doing anti-semitism is not
quite as likely to lead to specific
violence it is much more likely to lead
to widespread anti-semitic acts against
the state of israel collectively for
example or to legislation the targets
Jews in places like Belgium it's much
more likely to lead to government action
because left doing anti-semitism has
been mainstreamed so right-wing
anti-semitism has not been mainstreamed
it's basically been cast out it's a
group of small it's a small group of
people who are exceedingly dangerous in
how they interact with other people but
it's a small group left doing
anti-semitism is less specifically
dangerous but more broadly dangerous in
the sense that it leads to broad
political changes that target Jews this
would be people like Johan Omar who has
made anti-semitic references repeatedly
and then is given the green light by the
Democratic Party celebrated put on the
cover of Rolling Stone they raise money
for her so it's a different type of
anti-semitism and it is a type of
anti-semitism that is more viral it's
more easy to spread among large groups
of people no hado martin tries to cover
for all of this i mean it's amazing
Ilhan omar yesterday was it was it some
rally and she said she can't fight
Islamophobia if she won't fight
anti-semitism well then i guess she's
not fighting Islamophobia because she
has not fought anti-semitism she's
engaged in anti-semitism when we are
talking about anti-semitism we must also
talk about Islamophobia is two sides of
the same coin of bigotry so I can't ever
speak of Islamophobia and fight for
Muslims if I am not willing to fight
against anti-semitism not been willing
to fight against anti-semitism now what
she says there about Islamophobia and
anti-semitism being two sides of the
same coin there's truth to that when
she's speaking about right-wing
anti-semitism
there are not two sides of the same coin
when it comes to left-wing
anti-semitism because left-wing
anti-semitism is based on the hierarchy
of intersectional grievances in which
case Muslims are victimized and Jews are
victimizers according to left-wing
extremists and this has become a
mainstream view inside the Democratic
Party which is why Ilhan Omar is still
praised it's also why the New York Times
will print openly anti-semitic cartoons
and then pretend they don't know what
they are doing the cartoonist who drew
that anti-semitic cartoon in The New
York Times earlier this week by the way
he said that it was not Nancy sematic
cartoon it was just an anti-israel
cartoon it's just an anti Zionist
cartoon ok well this is the convenient
cover of the left for their hatred of
Jews collectively any time shoes get
together in one place it's obviously as
seen as a bad thing
bye-bye anti-semitic members of the left
this guy it's a perfect example this guy
is on the left he hates Israel and he
really dislikes Jews how can tell he
dislikes Jews because he says this
cartoon is not anti-semitic he claimed
that the anti-semitism charges are a
misunderstanding quote made through the
Jewish propaganda machine which is
anytime there's criticism because
there's someone anti-semitic on the
other side and that's not the case he
says the Jewish right doesn't want to be
criticized and therefore when criticized
they say we are persecuted people we
suffered a lot this is anti-semitism so
is the Jewish propaganda machine but
he's not an anti-semite guys so that's
the left-wing anti-semitism not quite as
specifically dangerous to individual
Jews deeply dangerous to Jews across the
world who are then put at risk by both
government policies on a broad scale and
also by left-wing anti-semitism
tolerance for the third type of
anti-semitism which is radical Islamic
anti-semitism
now that is widespread across the Muslim
world unfortunately by polling data
anti-semitism and Muslim world is
certainly not uncommon there are
moderate and reformed Muslims who do not
believe this stuff but there are many
Muslims who do believe this stuff and
that does manifest not only in
government policies in Muslim countries
that crack down on Jews or bar Jews from
even entering but also it is manifest in
specific acts of terrorism that have
taken place across Europe so in Europe a
lot of the attacks that are taking place
against Jews are Muslim and orientation
and they are made room before by by the
left wing that has suggested that
anti-semitism is really just
anti-zionism the kind of the apex case
of this being the burning of a synagogue
in Germany that was ruled to be an ant
dynast incident not an anti-semitic
incident by a local court so those are
the three types of anti-semitism and as
we remember the Holocaust today and the
murder of six million Jews is worthwhile
to remember that any form of
anti-semitism that collectively seeks to
destroy the Jews as a people and target
them as a people those forms of
anti-semitism are not far from what
happened in the Holocaust nor are they
dead they're very much alive and they
are thriving in in certain fringe areas
of the right and certain mainstream
areas of the left and in certain
mainstream areas of the radical Muslim
world we have to keep our eye on that or
we fall prey to the possibility of
greater evil in the future okay time for
some things that I like and then some
things that I hate so things that I like
today today is Yom Hashoah and Yom
Hashoah rec is is the Memorial Day for
the Holocaust for folks who have never
actually seen any of the footage from
the Holocaust it is worthwhile to do so
yes there are fictional films about the
Holocaust that are worth seeing
obviously there was a there was a
miniseries called Shoah that is very
good Schindler's List is is a very good
film if you haven't seen there was a
there's a miniseries called
uprising about the Warsaw Ghetto
Uprising that I think is is well worth
watching and then there's there's entire
documentary series I would watch the
documentaries because the fictionalized
film accounts don't do justice to what
exactly happened in the camps and what
exactly was the movement to put Jews
particularly specifically target Jews
this was not just a question of the
Nazis killing millions of people this
was the specific targeting of Jews for
their Jewish ancestry anybody who was at
least 1/4 Jewish was considered capable
of being slaughtered by the Nazis six
million Jews go to the gas chambers or
are shot in mass shootings everyone
focused on the gas chambers people
forget that mass graves were dug and
Jews were shot on mass above the mass
graves millions of Jews died that way as
well and the act of the brutal nature of
humanity
is worthy of note if you actually want
to prevent brutality in the future we
have to realize that there is a true
dark side to human nature is also great
heroism to human nature if you read
Viktor Frankl you see how people found
purpose and kindness and generosity even
in the midst of the greatest act of
collective victimization in the history
of humankind by numbers
you know the victor
his book man's search for meaning or
elie wiesel tonight I was privileged to
be able to help ghost write the
autobiography of Jack's llama vet Jack's
alum of ik was Elie Wiesel 's cousin he
was with him in Auschwitz and Jack
Slovak then came to the United States he
became an immigrant to the United States
his story is really pretty amazing I was
privileged because I know his son-in
Friends of his son as he was dying he
had he was diagnosed with with late
stage cancer I had the privilege of
sitting with him for hours and hours as
he told me stories of what exactly had
happened during the Holocaust
slimovitz story is pretty amazing and I
want to tell it to you now he he passed
away in 2011 he was born in 1925 in a
little town in Czechoslovakia called
salat fina with the outbreak of World
War two the Hungarians took over the
town they implemented anti-jewish laws
at the behest of the Nazis in 1944 the
Germans themselves then came and
occupied solid fina and they moved to
all the Jews into a ghetto and from
there the Jews were shipped directly to
Auschwitz slum of ik was shipped with
his father his two uncles and his cousin
Elie Wiesel to buna which was a labor
camp near a schvitz his mother five of
his siblings were immediately separated
from them and then sent to be gassed to
death in the chambers over the next year
slow move it was shuttled to several
concentration camps whose forced on
death marches he was able to steal small
bits of food to keep his family alive he
tried to protect his father all the way
through the Holocaust who somehow kept
his father who was ailing alive all the
way to the end of the Holocaust but
literally the day before liberation to
raise instead his father had already
become deadly ill with typhus and died
in his arms days after the liberation
interets inch that some of extorting
story of how human beings are able to
rise from the ashes he wandered the
streets of Prague people don't know this
but in the aftermath of World War two
after the liberation Jews went back in
many cases to their homes in some of
these Eastern European countries and
those homes had been occupied by
non-jews something like ten thousand
Jews were murdered in the aftermath of
World War two simply for going back to
their homes and saying no one of their
homes back and then the people who are
living there were killed them in any
case slum of ik wandered the streets of
Prague eventually he found his way to
the Sudetenland and sought an American
visa by the time he got his visa war had
broken out in the nascent State of
Israel
and instead of using that visa to travel
to the United States instead Salaam of
avant eared to be smuggled into Israel
to fight on behalf of the Jewish state
they took him off the boat they gave him
two hours of training they handed him a
rifle and then they sent him to the
front lines of Latrun which was the
bloodiest battle of the independence war
now when folks talk about Israel being
unnecessary the fact that millions of
Jews have been slaughtered throughout
history the fact that the population of
Jews in today's world is still lower
than the population of Jews in 1940 you
know that is why the State of Israel
exists to protect Jews all over the
world and to give Jews a place to go
when things go bad that is one of the
reasons for the Jewish state to exist on
just a practical root level and as an
it's funny the same people who say
Israel is unnecessary the same people
who are making room for anti-semitic
attacks on Jews they say Israel is
unnecessary Israel's bad and also
anti-jewish act in the West are just
anti-israel acts do you think we believe
you really do you think we believe you
then when you say you're just anti
Zionist and therefore it's okay for
people to be anti-semitic against Jews
you think that we believe that if you
got rid of the State of Israel suddenly
you'd be nice to the Jews I have my
doubts in any case the salam of ik was
shipped over to the front lines of
Latrun 150 people went into battle along
with slow moving and only 15 came out in
one piece some avec actually became a
guy who served behind enemy lines he was
good at it he met Prime Minister David
ben-gurion who gave him a bottle of
vodka before one particularly dangerous
mission and Salaam avec was part of all
of these secret missions at the end of
the war Salameh belt that his role was
done he moved to the United States in a
6th grade education he worked as a day
laborer and a night watchman to make
ends meet and then he began working as
an apprentice to an electrician and then
finally he went out on his own he
literally walked the streets looking for
jobs on which he could bed within a few
years he was running a full electricity
store with a bunch of employees and then
he eventually became a millionaire
became a pillar of the LA Jewish
community supporting local schools and
synagogues came trustee of the Jim
Joseph Foundation which is a billion
dollar endowment focused on Jewish
education the Holocaust is a grave act
of evil the anti-semitism that supported
the Holocaust still lives in many human
hearts and the possibility of that
darkness still exists please go watch
the footage today in honor of the people
who died and remember that evil is never
is never truly gone on for
but neither is good neither is good and
that good is there that's why we have to
stand between between the evil and and
those it would victimize ok time for a
quick thing that I hate so I lied this
thing abhi quick so I saw Avengers end
game last night with my wife now I
didn't hate it ok it's a little strong
to say that I hated Avengers end game
but I and I don't really like throwing
cold water on people's favorite movies
and the things that they love all a lot
well I won't say I don't like doing it I
I don't enjoy it more than I should
in any case Avengers end game it is 1
million hours long is the vogner Ian
ring cycle and it has moments but
they're a bunch of spoilers coming guys
it does not work as a film it does not
work as a film it basically destroys all
of the main characters that you actually
care about in favor of a bunch of
characters you don't it's got the Star
Wars problem so the new Star Wars
basically took all the characters you
liked and killed them off to make room
for characters that you don't actually
care about it relies on the nostalgia
that you have for the last 16 films and
it is a cool thing that they were
somehow able to put together 16 films
that led all the way up to this final
film like that's that's really a neat
achievement on a cinematic level the
problem is none of this works and they
destroy all of your favorite characters
with probably the exception of Black
Widow Scarlett Johansson who finally
gets a character arc that is worthy of
her acting skills so here are all the
spoilers so Iron Man obviously plots is
right at the end iron man dies Iron
Man's character arc is the only
interesting thing in this movie but they
totally botch it the reason that they
botch it is because iron man Robert
Downey jr. is character for all of his
movies the struggle for Iron Man has
been not do I go save the world or am i
selfish that solved in movie one right
the rest of the movies are all about
will he settle down with with pots will
he will he settle down will he build the
family can he contain himself will he
become a solid citizen right that was
the struggle of Robert Downey jr. when
was he gonna grow up and be an adult
that was the question of Robert Downey
jr. and after fan oh snaps his fingers
in the first 45 minutes of the movie you
find out that Robert Downey jr. has
gotten married to Pepper Potts and then
he has actually had a kid with her and
this is good right this is a good set up
and then there and then it arises
through really dumb coincidence hey guys
have you
the idea of time travel have you thought
about it like seriously and then people
and then Robert engineer is like oh man
well I guess and I haven't thought about
it's impossible oh I have five minutes
here send in five minutes he comes up
with a time travel plan so forget about
how silly that is it comes with the time
travel plan in the next five minutes
it's an Avengers film you can't look for
you know them to him to spend four years
trying to figure out how time travel
works or anything like that but here's
the problem now Tony Stark has stakes
the stakes are and they present this
choice it's ready to be made the stakes
are do you go back and change the past
and thus lose what you have built for
yourself in the aftermath of you
becoming a mature human being lose a
daughter do you sacrifice your own
daughter to save the world right that's
a real moral choice but then they
obviate that choice in the next 30
seconds of the film where they explain
that if they go back and change the past
it won't actually change this timeline
and therefore Tony Stark's kid will
still be alive and his wife will still
be alive and everything will be
hunky-dory
so now this just becomes another Iron
Man film where it's about Tony Stark
risking himself to go save the world but
there are no heightened stakes at all so
you've built up to his final character
transformation into responsible human
being and the question is gonna be now
is he even more responsible than the
responsible human being he's built a
family now is he willing to sacrifice
his own family and his own happiness in
order to save the world and the answer
is we're not gonna make him answer the
question because there were none of the
guts to actually posed that choice so
that's the problem with Iron Man's
character Captain America's character
the problem with Captain America's
characters they've always gotten it
wrong so Captain America is basically
John McCain he's supposed to be this
Prachi the old guy in a young guy's body
a guy a man out of time Captain America
has never felt like a man out of time to
me he's just felt like generic superhero
who's kind of dope being a good guy
that's the way Chris Evans has played
him and this isn't just Chris because
Chris Evans dislikes me Chris Evans
apparently like the people who write the
script basically felt that he would just
be like any normal guy like if you saw
Captain America without the uniform he
wouldn't know he's Captain America he's
just the guy well that's not how the
character is in the comics and that's
not how the character should be here so
the stakes for Captain America aren't
extraordinarily high now Captain America
is ending where they have him basically
go back in time and then he is able to
and then he basically just stays
back in time with the love of his life I
was fine with that I really didn't have
a huge problem with his ending I thought
his ending was the most appropriate I
thought iron man dying even that
would've been appropriate if they had
set it up properly that was okay the
person who I really couldn't stand what
they did with him was Thor so I what
they did with Thor makes no sense on a
character level so I understand you guys
wanted to joke
you wanted Thor with the dad bod got it
okay you want him to be fat and burp a
lot and be Big Lebowski okay it's funny
for the first five minutes and then it's
this is not Thor right we've had several
four movies at this point Thor's problem
has never been lack of courage it's how
it's always been that he is afraid that
he does not have the moral fiber to be
the leader it's been that he's afraid of
leadership that's been his mortal
conflict is that he's been afraid of
leadership the whole time and leadership
has to be thrust upon him and then he
realizes he's leader but instead they
decided to go the direction of not that
he doesn't want to take leadership but
that he's afraid to participate himself
and he won't even participate and so
they make him basically a drunk weakling
and it's silly and you never actually
get to see Thor really in action because
they've decided to saddle him with a fat
suit for the joke which is again not in
character and also very silly guy was
waiting for the point where Thor would
just kind of take the hammer or the axe
and slam it on the ground the Lightning
comes and he's back to being old Thor
right I was waiting for that sort of
transformation that never really happens
and in fact the best thing about Thor is
in the first five minutes of the film
when he kills Thanos right then the
first five minutes of the film we're
chaps tano's his head off that's the
best thing that he's got in the entire
film the rest of the time he's basically
wasted which is a pity because Chris
Hemsworth naturally holds his own
on-screen I don't think Chris Evans can
I think Chris Chris Hemsworth can with
Robert Downey jr. but they don't give
him anything to do except be funny which
he is I mean in that that there's a
final kind of thing with Chris Pratt and
Chris Hemsworth that's very funny okay
but he was supposed to be more than a
funny character if you watched the first
Thor film directed by Kenneth Branagh it
was supposed to be far more serious also
as my business partner
Jeremy boring has pointed out that that
it's pretty obvious from the film that
they wanted Anthony Hopkins to come back
and do a scene with Chris Hemsworth and
Chris Hemsworth they weren't able to get
homes worth to do it so instead they
brought back Rene Russo for a
conversation and it really doesn't work
fantastically well Thanos is built up in
the first Avengers film as this guy
within
backstory and with an actual with an
actual rationale right he feels that
balance has to be brought back because
he lived on a planet where
overpopulation was a problem so he snaps
his fingers half the people are gone
balance is restored
hey now they bring us back to old Thanos
who still has that same mission and they
basically just turned him into Big Daddy
right now he doesn't have an interesting
backstory now he's just a sadist
and there's a line near the end of the
film where he turns to Robert Downey jr.
or Captain America I can't I think it's
maybe Captain America and he says I you
know your little planet I'm going to
enjoy destroying it okay come on come on
like if you want to draw a good villain
then you can't just make them a sadist
every bad villain like Steppenwolf from
Justice League is just to say this who
wants to do bad stuff but danos had an
interesting backstory and the thing
about Thanos is that danos was willing
to sacrifice his own daughter for what
he believed in right Danno said he's
immoral he's a bad person but he's
willing to make a sacrifice they don't
even ask Robert Downey jr. to make in
the second Avengers film so that is a
problem as well now there are two
characters who I do think are treated
well by the script Black Widow is
treated well by the script
Hawkeye Jeremy Renner is treated well by
the script Carol Danvers the the Captain
Marvel character I just have to say that
she's insanely boring so I didn't
actually see the Captain Marvel film I'm
intending on going and seeing it at some
point I didn't really feel the
compunction to see it but I suppose that
I will see it in any case she's in the
film but she's basically a block of wood
the breaks things right that's what
Carol Danvers says she doesn't have any
character you don't know why she's there
she don't you don't know her motivations
she just flies around and she smashes
things alright and she's and she's a sex
Mak enough another point made by my
business partner we had a conversation
about this this morning is that one of
the problems with with this film is that
you also don't know the comparative
power of the characters so it's like
every character has a power that is
equally powerful despite the fact that
they don't there's a scene near the end
where the inventors headquarters hit by
1 million missiles and somehow ant-man
who is a human and and Jeremy Renner who
is a human are fine but at the bottom of
20 stories they're fine totally cool
that makes no sense and there's a scene
where Thanos who does not have the
Infinity Gauntlet at this point is
fighting off
Captain America and Thor and Iron Man
but
all three of them well if you remember
back to the first Avengers film he
barely holds off Thor alone right Thor
shows up and Thor nearly takes him out
well he has the Infinity stone so if he
doesn't have the Infinity stones he's
basically just a big bad guy so why are
all three of them unable to take him out
and then there was the NFL ad
recapitulation where they're trying to
run the gauntlet between players and
it's like oh okay I understand you're
doing fanservice look there's Black
Panther ooh there's spider-man oh look
they're handing it to this other
character who we don't care about yay
and then they're just kind of throwing
in the gauntlet just to remind you that
all these characters exist
okay the center of this universe was
always supposed to be Iron Man Captain
America Thor they turned Thor into a
loser Captain America is boring an Iron
Man they don't give a full motivation
and prohibit him from making a proper
choice now they're again scenes in this
movie that are quite good the scene
between the Hulk for example the Mark
Ruffalo character and until the sweatin
the doctor the character from Doctor
Strange right that's actually a good
seed right the scene there are a couple
of the scene with Robert Downey jr. and
his dad that's a good scene too but
overall I felt like it was a mishmash I
felt like it didn't really work I
understand that for uber fans of Marvel
I'm not speaking as an uber fan of Marlo
I've seen virtually all of these films I
think that Captain Marvel is the is the
only one that I have not seen but
they're over fans who are sitting there
like just picking out the Easter eggs Oh
remember when they did that in this
movie and then we're flashing back to
that movie now isn't that cooler than
that funny and there's some of there's a
lot of stuff there but that's fanservice
it's not filmmaking and it doesn't give
an emotional resonance the only
emotional resonance really is Iron Man's
death which I guess is what it was
supposed to be and even there I felt
like it was diminished somewhat by the
fact that he basically just dies in a
normal adventure story that could have
taken place in any of the other Iron
Man's also final critique I don't feel
the necessity to have a giant battle
with all of the people in the universe
at the end of every movie I didn't like
it at the end of Aquaman I don't like it
here in fact the battle was much more
interesting when it was just a couple of
people fighting before all of these
things show up before Doctor Strange
unleashes the Beast and all these people
come walking through back from the dead
it felt throughout the movie like there
were no snakes and this is my big
problem I didn't get anything that I
thought was really unexpected I felt
like they deliberately lowered the
stakes not heighten the stakes with that
decision that I referred to about I
man I felt like it was it was blase and
bland I didn't feel like anyone was
really in any danger and even iron man's
death is sort of inevitably foreshadowed
by what happens to the Hulk when he puts
on the gauntlet so yeah I wish I had
liked the movie more since I spent three
hours of my life on it and fifty bucks
the tickets for IMAX weren't expensive
man but but I will say that I understand
why people enjoyed it if you're a super
fan but I'm not going to but I am NOT up
with the this is great now where is the
future of Marvel this is a serious
question because when you look at the
second ranks of characters they've now
gotten rid of all their big stars right
Chris Hemsworth I guess might appear in
the future but not in a Thor movie I'll
probably do a cameo in the guardians of
the galaxy movie which is a Chris Pratt
property so guardians of the galaxy will
continue to be a functioning series cuz
all those characters are still there but
who's gonna be the new Iron Man it can
they replace Robert Downey jr. I don't
think so I really don't think so
he's too iconic and especially if they
decide to make it winneth Paltrow or
something she's been in all the movies
that she's not the reason people see
movies
do they really think that what's the
name of the character who our play the
Eagle who's gonna replace Captain
America and that's not gonna that's not
gonna play there are great black
superheroes right Black Panther is one
of them that's a that's a viable
property I don't think that just sliding
the Eagle into into Captain America's
suit by the way does he have any
superpowers at all like Captain America
took the serum is the guy who's becoming
new Captain America does he have the
serum or is just a human with a shield
as for Thor they really think they can
replace Chris Hemsworth with Valkyrie
and again the character arc for Thor is
doesn't exist so his whole character arc
is he refuses to take leadership but
he's the best among us and thus he will
receive the hammer right that is Thor's
character arc and if he end not only
does he not receive the hammer but also
he then hands off the mantle of
leadership which he has been attempting
to avoid his entire life so it's never
thrust upon him and he never takes it so
in the last Thor movie he actually does
take it right in the last Thor movie he
is forced to take it right he loses his
eye he becomes weathered he loses the
long hair he loses the beard right
suddenly he is you know the king that
his father was and by the end of this
movie he's back to being the loser he
was at the beginning of movie number one
so lots of problems with the movie Paul
runs into good jobs hand man okay we're
done we'll be back here later with a
couple more hours this is the Ben ship
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua ov era
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright daily wire 20 19
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show students at Hofstra
University are demanding the school tear
down a statue of Thomas Jefferson
meanwhile in Northern California public
school district wants to remove a mural
of George Washington we will analyze the
end of history check it out at Daily
wire calm